listen next loving for Allah look how
important is how many of us love for
Allah how many people in this day and
age with social media they're liking
things that Allah hates they're posting
on their accounts things that Allah
hates
subh how can you like something publicly
that Allah hates Islam said the one who
publicly demonstrates their love of
something Allah hates they're not from
the oah of
Allah because you're loving something
that Allah
hates look the healthy the healthy
heart if they love they love for Allah
yes they don't love based upon
gangs that is why the complete
believer is not in any gang not in any
Jama part to your
group no
clicks if they love they love for Allah
n not based upon the color of skin not
based upon a person being white or black
or Arab or
non-arab if they love they love for
Allah that's the healthy heart if your
heart is not like that it's diseased
you're
sick